une journée pour sensibiliser aux
nombreuses injustices subies par les
enfants en france et dans le monde à
montigny le bretonneux les enfants
étaient nombreux ce mercredi 24 novembre
à l'hôtel de ville au programme des
animations de sensibilisation menées par
les équipes d'animation des accueils de
loisirs et du conseil municipal des
jeunes comme des plaques où les enfants
pouvaient dessiner ce que représente
leur droit à leurs yeux scellé droit que
normalement tous les enfants devraient
avoir être soigné avoir une nationalité
être coté être protégés avoir une
famille
avoir le droit de s'exprimer tous les
enfants ont droit d'aller à l'école tous
les enfants ont droit bah de manger à
leur faim et de boire la tasse toi une
famille on a le droit d'avoir une
nationalité les enfants pouvaient
également planter des fleurs aux
couleurs de l'unicef et de
l'organisation des nations unies au pied
de l'arbre des droits de l'enfant ira
donc ces trois lettres non convention
universelle des droits des enfants qui
vont être
sauvés être fleuris aux couleurs de
l'onu et de l'unicef donc bleu et blanc
et pour avoir une trace visible des
droits des enfants sur cette arme des
quiz des mots mêlés ou encore un memory
pour en apprendre plus sur leurs droits
un enjeu important pour la ville de
montigny le bretonneux qui fait partie
du réseau villes des enfants depuis des
1017 nous considérons à montigny que la
jeunesse est une richesse une richesse
importante pour le pays pour l'avenir et
qu'on doit vraiment beaucoup investir
pour 7 pour pour nos enfants pour la
jeunesse une journée des droits de
l'enfant plus que jamais nécessaire
selon l'unicef la crise sanitaire fait
peser des menaces sur la santé la
sécurité et le bien-être et l'avenir des
enfants ces derniers ont vu leur
quotidien bouleversé par le virus avec
la fermeture des écoles les différents
confinement ou encore l'arrêt des
activités physiques ou de loisirs des
faits qui vont creuser davantage encore
des inégalités existantes